[Musique]
1500 courageux du dimanche matin se sont
donné rendez vous pour le trail des
anglais
une foule de sportifs prêt à découvrir
un sentier mythique le chemin des
anglais
parmi eux le top de la discipline et
surtout une masse de sportifs motivés
il est mal placé le poteau la folle
déplacer beaucoup d'ambition ce matin
bonne chose ça à moi j'aime bien parce
que c'est varié pas des cailloux ou
telle page
même au niveau des de la visitation c
c'est varié très variés puisque le plus
à leurs audits orale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette journée j'espère c'est à dire ça
quand j'aurai fait une passante a fini
sur la ligne l'ambiance était la
performance et dès les premiers
kilomètres les choses se sont confirmées
les 6 premiers kilomètres de routes ont
été avalés à 18 km heure c'est ce qu'on
appelle des athlètes
[Musique]
pour la majorité des coureurs l'ambiance
est toute autre au centre de cette carte
postale chatoyantes les montagnes russes
et l'idéal désorganisé calme rapidement
les ardeurs ce qui te parle la nike
running ok elle te dis pas bouge-toi
accélère non il faut se connecter sur
facebook c'est vraiment sociale comme
sport
[Applaudissements]
ce territoire du conservatoire du
littoral sous la gestion du département
de la réunion est unique par son
histoire avec notamment le lazaret
beaucoup de nos ancêtres sont arrivés à
la réunion par cette zone de quarantaine
ici c'est initier le métissage
réunionnais
la suite de l'histoire sédentaires de
travail et ça c'est pour bientôt
c'est parti
[Musique]
pendant que certains profitent du cadre
les premiers sont déjà la redoute que
voilà un beau geste et comment alors
mettez mémorable c'est le mot qui vient
à l'esprit parce que ce n'est pas le
mettrais affection est exceptionnel il a
su garder son sang froid alors qu'il y
avait plus de 30 degrés mais on est
heureux d'être ici dans une victoire ici
langue en une très belle performance est
belle 2e place aura pour thème de
l'année dernière c'est ça
c'est quasiment à 7
mais le même temps déjà
sa forme garde le sport est un atout le
sport c'est la vie
[Musique]
comme un goût de diagonale des fous en
début d'année une certitude
ce sentier ne laissera jamais personne
indifférent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]